the jurgen experience do you
cry ever i cry for happy things
yeah most of the time i cry when i'm
happy for people but i cry if i think
about
you know like people that i miss and you
know stuff like that
that's good i definitely cry yeah
well i i cry a lot for like things that
make me happy
that's uh that's really yeah that's cute
yeah i cry for people
i cry when i'm happy for people but uh
yeah i cry i feel that
i know i'm not scared of emotions yeah
you know
nice yeah i'm scared of
weakness i don't like weakness but i
don't think crying is weakness i think
it's weak to not want to cry i think
it's
not it's weak to not want to embrace the
full spectrum of life
you know life is filled with beautiful
things and
amazing things and it's also filled with
horrible things like they're all there
and to deny that i think is to deny
reality
it is and that is to be delusional i'm
afraid of being delusional more than i'm
afraid of crying
i think it's really important that you
just said that you cry and you think
it's important
because i think so many people that
listen to you do not
so many men don't cry joe you know that
they do i think they just don't want
people to know well maybe they don't but
i just don't think they'll allow
themselves to and i'm i put myself in
that category like it's
really hard for me to cry like i have to
i have to
be talking to someone about my i have to
have it kind of mirrored back to me
my emotions so that i can have license
to cry but
it's not something that that comes
naturally to people but i think it's
important to do
which i cried on the podcast real
recently really
yeah there was a guy on uh josh dubin
from the
he's a lawyer and they were talking
about the innocence project he works
with the innocence project and
they uh got this uh poor man who is an
immigrant
i believe he's from guatemala who was
unjustly accused of murder and they they
got him out and you know they were just
going through the whole story
about how the prosecutors were trying to
keep him in jail even though he knew he
was innocent and they
they finally got him released and
they're talking about this thing and i
just started crying
yeah this poor guy he's thinking about
this guy who like makes his way to
america to try to do better for himself
and
it winds up getting caught up in this
this fake murder
this god accusation and yeah yeah i
cried about that i
yeah i just i think men need to cry more
and and is that another one of your
folders
yeah men crying and then i'm seriously
turned on by men crying i love it
can i really put that out there i uh the
one time my ex-boyfriend cried in front
of me
you got hot i was blowing him while he
was like still
like sniffling like still his tears were
like hitting me on the head
i'm not joking you it was i felt so
inappropriate doing it but i was like
this is so hot that you are opening up
and you are emoting
and that i don't have to deal with these
feelings on a in another way which is
you being mad at me are you like
bottling up your anger i mean these
feelings have to come out somewhere it
just was so erotic to me to see a guy
like
so so sensitive